- When you get drunk, it numbs
the
part of you that would
normally laugh at yourself
for doing something sexy.
- Yes, yes.
- Cause when you're drunk and
you're like,
is this your scarf? (laughs)
- Yes.
- Sober I'd be like yes, this is
a very
nice scarf, my hands are
up here, hands are up here.
- I know you can be--
- Hello.
- Like I'm Kate Beckinsale,
I pretend like I can be--
- I'm Pete Davidson. I don't
know.
- (laughs) Exactly.
- Can I see your boobs?
(bass music)
- We need some sort of patch.
- Yeah.
- For--
- Like a wine patch.
- [Russell] Like a wine patch.
- Called the Pinot Noir.
- [Russell] Very good.
- Yeah, you just put it on
and your lips get purple.
- I swear to god--
- And you go, I'll fuck you
right now.
- But imagine some sort of patch
that gives you the sort
of lack of inhibition
that booze gives you, but
it isn't actually alcohol.
Whatever that is.
- I think it's oxy.
- Yeah.
Cool, so I'm gonna be
fucking trying to get
Nikki out of Union Square in a
year
when she's in all black
and has a dog on the train
going, "I need a ticket home for
Buffalo."
And you go you're on fucking
heroin.
I know you're on heroin.
- She's had sex twice.
- And I am fucking.
- I am fucking.
- You know what you're doing
here when you're fucking
the park.
You get comfortable fucking
outside.
- Why don't you buy one
of those fuck machines?
- Like a sybian?
Oh jeez Andrew that's why you
go?
- No but she's..
- Honestly.
- The thing is me and Andrew,
we're trying to figure out
problems here,
so I would suggest
alongside the fuck machine,
why not a nice audio book
then you've got company.
- Yes, but during the
fuck machine or after?
- Guys I'm just gonna say
- During!
- Let's go in and make a
full fuck robot for Nikki,
let's weird science this.
- I can't wait until those
exist.
- They do!
- Give 'em a million
followers on Instagram.
- Can I respond to your
fuck machine thing.
Believe me I've thought about it
and believe me I
- It's too loud?
- First of all I have a small
apartment,
what am I gonna roll out my fuck
machine,
my maid is gonna like dust
around it.
- You gotta thing of gas
and go hold on real quick
Conseula I'm just gassing
up this thing real quick.
(boom)
- But that's where the
audiobook comes in handy.
- What do you mean?
- I mean some sort of, maybe
a Charles Dickens novel.
- It was the best of times
- So it doesn't feel so dirty
- No, I could just like watch
porn
and put on the fuck machine.
- Well that's gonna give the
game away.
- When I'm a rich lady in a big
house,
I'll have a room with a fuck
ma...
Like I will 100% buy a fuck
machine.
- Can you have a bunch of locks
on it,
where you go you guys wanna see
the room?
(laughter)
You open the door, you go
that's a big fuck machine.
You go I know.
- Can I tell you what I do,
I have come up with a way
to have, to get fucked
without a fuck machine right on
your own.
- This is what Edison did.
- So there are certain toys,
there's one,
there's toys that like
move on their own right
like they have like a bend
in them and it goes like
or it swirls.
- It looks like it's a small
world after all at Disneyland,
like the way they move.
- Yes.
- Where it's like (musical
noise)
- There's ones that like do
a come heather motion okay
so a lot of times I'll but I
don't even wanna hold it there
because I'm just like, then I
have to be
in this like weird crunch
position.
So I plugged my heel with
it and then lay it back.
- Dildo hack.
- Then it's working and
you're not doing anything,
and you're just getting the...
- It's like a life hack but for
sex toys.
- It really is.
- But does it not hurt,
that looks like you're
gonna get a cramp of some form.
- And I put a dimmer switch on
my Hitachi
which I'm sitting on, I
just put that on my butt,
I sit on that and I have
a dimmer switch with that
so I'm doing minimal work.
- There is a Japanese
scientist that is so upset
you don't know about his
product.
(laughter)
I have a whole fuck machine
you do not need to put
your heel on your pussy.
And then it just comes to the
room like (mechanical noise),
dude I'd worry if I was a
woman and I fucked a machine
it would just kill me.
- [Nikki] Oh yes.
- That's the thing, gen
when you sort of worry
that you do it too wildly and it
would
make a citizens arrest and the
robot
would just take you in to the
street.
- And just lifts you up by
your face like (screams)
- Safe word
- There's one in the UK
they're developing sex robots in
the UK.
One in five British people
said they would have sex
with a robot.
- Yeah I would.
- I would fuck a robot in a
second.
- John Connor, I ain't fucking
no robot.
- I'm kind of with you.
- Are you afraid of it?
- No it's Wallace and Gromit
- You like it too much.
- Have you not seen Wallace
and Gromit the wrong trousers.
- No.
- Yeah so basically
there's like a cartoon,
there's this sort of robot I
would worry
that the robot would just
take you out in the street.
- Exactly.
- But the interesting thing
is they're developing one.
- Yeah but it doesn't have
legs it's just a pussy.
- No no it's.
- Would the pussy pick you up?
- No no no, it's an actual sex
robot.
- Like a woman.
- A woman or a man.
- I don't need appendages.
- But they've developed
it with a Scottish accent.
- Really?
- [Russell] Yeah out of
all the accents to choose.
- That is fucking hilarious,
fuck harder, go harder,
fuck me harder.
- Of all the accents you could
choose.
- Like a man's Scottish accent
is maybe a little bit sexy
but never a woman.
- On a woman robot.
- Whack it in my cracker, whoa.
- With hairy forearms.
- Fucking cock is great.
- Every tool though is a robot
in some way and use robotics.
- Use a remote control.
- You're doing the same line of
thinking
that men do at bars when
they're just trying to hook up,
you go what is a robot, robots.
- What is sex, what is yeah.
- I'm gonna fuck a machine so
what.
It's just I'm worried
that it'll just turn.
- Well Dan did you struggle
with having sex sober
after you got sober.
- Oh no you definitely
don't cum right away
when that happens.
- Oh yeah yeah.
- It definitely happens you quit
drinking
you're like sex, I'm done.
- Yep
- Yeah
- And you're like oh my god.
- But I mean getting
to the place where you
can be comfortable enough to
have sex, I feel like guys
don't struggle as much.
- I started going to coffee.
You know what's worse to try to
have sex,
is to drink a bunch of caffeine.
- Yeah I mean that's the same.
- And then you're just
like do you wanna fuck.
- I know.
- I found it so much creepier
when my drunks friends
would get sober and drink
Red Bull to stay up,
to like wait around 2.30.
- No I can't do that.
- That's fucking creepy,
do you know what I mean
like you're just waiting for
just like a wounded deer.
- I've like hung out with girls
that have gotten too drunk
and I'm like we're not gonna...
- No that's yeah I'm sure
now you see it so clearly.
- But you're like stop and
they're like I wanna have fun.
- Ugh it's so gross.
- Oh sweet oh sweet thing no you
don't.
- I know it's hard to put up
with.
- I'm sexy now.
- You go, I used to feel
that, I know exactly
what you're feeling
right now but it's not.
- I Would make you so
many promises right now
if I was hammered.
- Oh my god.
- Be a lot of you know we're
gonna go away together.
- Yep
- And now I'm like
you probably need to go home.
- Well I just talked about the
first time that I was tested
as a sober person, like my
favorite thing to do drunk
I was talking about Andrew like
some of my best memories
are like when I drink
and had fun and going to
Lollapalooza,
and getting wasted was my
favorite yearly thing to do.
- Yeah.
- And the first time I
went sober was with you.
- Guess who was still drinking.
- And you were still drinking,
yeah.
Yeah that was such a test, in
that I never went back again.
Like you can't do musical
festivals, do you do ...
- Without drunk Dan?
- [Nikki] Are there certain
things that you can't do anymore
- That's a good point
though, a musical festival
is a tough one.
- It is.
- Yeah.
- I went to Coachella to
the first time two years ago
and that blew my mind, and
I wasn't drinking there.
- Really, so you were
just there stone sober.
- I'd never been to an American
musical festival before,
just compared to like
Glastonbury in England,
the same but completely
different.
Like the show, it was
incredible like everyone
was just, as soon as the band
started everyone turned around
and were kind of filming
it with themselves in it.
So the performers were
performing to nobody.
- [Dan] I really thought
this was about to be like
American fans give it up for the
bands.
- I know, I was so impressed
at the beginning of it
I was like is he not gonna shit
on us?
- No no but comedy
audiences here are amazing.
- [Nikki] Oh really?
- Compared to the UK yeah.
- I'm doing fringe this year
I'm like fuck am I in trouble.
- Are you, are you doing
Edinburgh?
- [Dan] Yeah yeah.
- Oh it'll be grand man,
it's lovely, where abouts?
- I'm at the Dairy and the
Underbelly.
- Oh lovely stuff yeah it's
great.
- I'm worried that you said
that 'cause you're like
they're not good like you know.
- Why are they different,
why are UK crowds.
- Well my thing is I don't
think,
'cause American's don't
have much holidays,
you have two weeks holiday
so I think when you go
out it has to matter.
Whereas in the UK, we have five
weeks off
so yeah.
- Oh so your vacation time
you're like...
- I think you put so much
energy into an evening out
because you have to work
so hard in this country,
that you are gonna make sure
it's good.
- [Nikki] So you get.
- I know at least one person
listening
that when you say that you hear
god damn right we work hard.
- No but absolutely.
- Like where it gets
fucking, god damn right,
80 hours a week.
- It's hammer and irons.
- But musical festival it just
blew my
and there was in Coachella,
there were certain areas
where you were allowed to take
booze but others you weren't.
- Yeah.
- So weird.
- We basically are still
children like we're.
- But at a musical festival
that's like
if you go to like Glastonbury.
I'm remember driving like I was
backstage,
I was doing a gig there
and I'm kind of driving
a car through.
- A little steering wheel
- There's like thousands
I'm like driving through.
And there's the guy,
this guy was shit faced
probably about 50 at the time
and I turned to my girlfriend
and was like that's my uncle.
Like in the middle of all these
people
there's this old guy
that was just bollocksed,
and that's what the UK gigs are
like,
just music gigs people just
wasted.
There's always one bloke that
will wake up
in Glastonbury after the
festival counting eggs
in some factory, he's been
stolen by some Christian's
in some weird commune.
- [Dan] And just shipped off.
- Mate it's proper wild.
So it was amazing to see
everybody here's your beer area.
- Very organized,
everyone's dressed so cute.
- Oh my little daisy flower
crown.
- Yep, yep, have you
been to Coachella before?
- Never will and never will
- I don't think I'll ever go
either, burning man I
might I feel like that.
- Bono roo twice got it.
- Yeah Bonnaroo.
- Jazz fest.
- Glastonbury's worth going to
though,
if you wanna sort of see a side
of England
that you probably
haven't seen in the films
that come out over here.
Go there and you'll see a wild
side.
- Just getting fuck, you
guys just get hammered.
- [Russell] Yeah it's great.
- Drinking is more I feel like
in the UK
drinking is a lot more.
- It's like the fucking purge at
weekends.
- [Dan] Really.
- Like (horn) we have two days
to live.
- Don't you like drinking, I
don't know you get off earlier.
- Are we just very
unhappy people, just get.
- Cloudy all the time, you
guys are just fucking hammered.
- Pale and disgusting.
- Dan do you miss drinking,
ever.
- Sometimes.
- Like when?
- I had a moment about two weeks
ago
where I could feel the
back of my jaw fucking
starting to water 'cause I was
like
I just want a shot of whisky and
a beer.
- Really?
- And then immediately was like,
that's why I shouldn't have it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So is that just because
you will just go so wild.
- Walk by like a really Irish
dive bar.
- And is it but you think
you won't just have one,
you'll just have.
- Fucking 12 buddy.
- There's no one.
- I ain't coming back for one,
what do you think I'm just gonna
stop.
- But it's really because
my friend Al is an alcoholic
he is exactly, it always
fascinates me
that you just can't have that.
- I always was blown away,
I'm more upset with people
that can have a drink
and walk away, I think
you're the fucking weirdos.
- Yeah okay.
- I stay there 'till the very
end.
- I know.
- What happened to commitment?
- I used to.
- What happened to
seeing something through?
- I used to say to my friends,
I'd be like
let's get blackout time
I'd wanna blackout
- Oh my god I would do this,
We're gonna get hammered.
- That's what I miss,
Dan that is what I miss
is like we're gonna drink,
we're gonna ah, excitement.
- Yannis Parpis upset me
so much because one time
he put half a beer down and he
goes,
I'm gonna walk out of here,
I don't want that half a beer
and I go I'm gonna drink that
beer
and he goes that's why
I put it right there,
he goes that's who you are.
- Yep, you're like
- You're gonna drink half
my beer and I was like fucking I
am.
- I am that girl too yep yep.
(crosstalk)
It ain't a fucking
handshake and how you doing.
- Well you are going to
Scotland for a month.
- I've already know.
- It's gonna be tough.
- I know that, every single
person I know
that knows I'm going over
there is they're like alright
be cool.
I mean I've already asked my
publicist,
I was like I need weed
just give me whatever,
I smoke weed.
- I'll get you a sex robot if
you want.
- Yes, I can't wait to
have my penis crushed.
- Do you ever feel.
- You see the sex robot
drinking, it's the only way I
can
- I'll go are you drunk,
she's like I have to,
this is how I warm up.
I go alright well you
seem a little hammered.
(laughter)
This is how, this what
lubricates my robotic vagina
is Guinness.
- (laughs) Guinness.
- Yeah I'm nervous man,
I'm really nervous.
- Well with weed, I struggle
with that
and I talk about it a lot
on the show is that you know
I love weed and it doesn't
ruin my life the way alcohol
did and I can still function,
highly function literally on
weed.
Do you feel the same, do you
ever feel guilty about it,
do you ever feel like hey
I'm gonna stop doing this.
- It's so weird because that
rubbing your hands together
when you're getting hammered
thing
I'm like when I'm done
with this radio show
I'm going home and getting
fucking ripped.
I'm smoking a joint, I'm
gonna watch that documentary
about Elizabeth and yeah.
I get high the way I you know
drink.
- Yes, very very high.
- I get very high and I love it.
- And I love it too, I have the
same,
Andrew's seen my when
I get done with shows
and I'm like I get to
have a joint, and it's.
- I smoke before shows
- In between shows,
before shows.
Oh see we used to talk
about this and you're like
you know what I do, I do it like
a treat,
you do the whole like I
do it only after shows,
I do it when I get home, I eat
my salad.
(laughter)
Dan doesn't smoke weed before
his sets,
I gotta be more like Dan,
thank you for admitting
that you do now.
- Oh my god what it is, is
it's like a it's to the point
where you know getting high I
think,
I talk about getting high the
same way
I used to talk about quitting
drinking,
where I'd be like I don't drink
whiskey,
I only have beer.
Yeah and that's what it
is I'm like only Indica.
- Do you really only do Indica?
- No, I smoke everything.
- No like it's.
- You give me fucking dirt weed
and I'd be like you gonna roll
this up.
- Yep you can Yannis you with
half of a.
- You leave a roach,
I'll fucking smoke it.
- But when you did the gravity
bong hit and you ended up.
- Do you know what a gravity
bong hit,
do you know what a gravity bong
is?
- I don't know what you're
talking about
I'll be honest with you, I erm.
- 'Cause weed is not, is
weed not big in the UK
as much as it is here?
- Not as a sort of teenage thing
no,
you sort of you just drink
from like 14 in the UK.
- And that's what I mean.
- Where as you guys start off
weed then.
- Yeah that's true.
- [Russell] We're already in
pubs I think.
- Yeah so you guys are
'cause you can go to a pub
and just have a pint.
- Yeah there's always one
place where some dodgy guy
will let you in and
everyone kind of goes in.
- And here in America they
really are like
no child should ever drink
alcohol.
- But you need ID, you
don't need ID to get
into pubs in the UK but
you sort of still do here.
- [Nikki] Yes.
- I smoked pot with my
mom in Portland last year
for a TV show that we did.
- How was it?
- It was great fun, yeah my
mom had never done it before.
- Really?
- Wow.
- My mom.
- [Russell] Go on.
- No I was gonna say
my mom used to get high
in the 60s and 70s.
- Oh really.
- And then it got legal
in Colorado, she was like.
- It's a different thing now.
- I'm gonna smoke weed with you
and we smoked weed and it's
not fun watching your mom
not be able to handle her shit.
- Oh no!
- That's not fun watching
your mom being like.
- Oh my god.
- We were this girls, this
girl that ran this shop
we kind went back to her
place and we kind of did
various versions of it.
And she had this lovely little
Chihuahua
and by the end of the session
you could tell that my mom was
eyeing up
that dog to eat.
Like genuinely we were
kind of going I said
would you have eaten that dog.
She was like yeah I would have
definitely,
I'd have put it on a George
Foreman grill
and eaten it in a bun.
- With the form in there.
- Yeah, we're imaging how
we were gonna cook it.
- What a fuck and the
Chihuahua's just sitting
in the room going who the fuck
are you.
- Well the dog seemed to
be like these guys are new.
- So watching your mom get high.
- It is interesting
seeing your parents get
like my parents get, when I see
them high
I love my mom high, she's a
delight
and she likes filming things.
That's her new thing when she
gets high,
she will just start
filming us and cabentry
and like around the house.
She just wants to document
the house 'cause I think
we're gonna sell it soon.
And I go dad what is she doing
and he goes that's your mom
new thing 'cause my mom
always has a new thing
when she gets fucked up that
she'll like.
For many years she was calling
us all,
or she would fire us if we got
mad,
she'd be like you're
fired and we'd be like
mom fired me three times last
night.
- I love that.
My mom says hello to me all
the time when she get hello
hello, hello.
(crosstalk)
- My mom would get wine teeth
and they'd get like purple
you know she would just cry
about things that don't exist
anymore.
- [Andrew] Like what?
- She's like Osco Drug closed,
I used to buy your birthday
cards there.
And you're like crying,
are we really crying
'cause the fucking drug store
closed.
- My mom did I reckon a 40
minute long improvised song
when she was drunk, two
Christmas ago.
- [Dan] Yeah!
- Taking my nan shopping.
- And she just.
- There was this great moment
where about 10 minutes in
my dad turned to my brother
went go get the camera.
- Yeah!
- Like that to record it.
- Did you know you had another
half hour.
- Was she liking grabbing her
ear like getting into it like.
- Well lot's of my cousins play
in bands
so they were just sort
of just playing along
and mom just grabbed it I'll
give you one
and it was this awful and
yet beautiful freestyle.
♪ We're down the aisle ♪
♪ What does she want, today
she might want chicken ♪
♪ Or she might not cause ♪
and it just went on.
- So that when she looks at
the guy playing the bass like
- It was and it kind of
they weirdly go in to it.
- That's so funny she goes a
little more.
(laughing)
and she's like yeah yeah how
they all bring it together
and she's like (terrible
singing)
(laughter)
that's fucking awesome.
- And she kept threatening to
stop,
do you know what I mean and
then she'd find another aisle.
What's this, it's bread, it's
bread.
- Oh that's a great setting for
a song,
you can just have a lot of
adventures.
- Exactly but what was funny
about it in a real OCD way
she did every, she did like the
- She hit the bull candies.
- Then she did the milk exactly.
- She took a sample.
- If I'm playing in the band I
go
hey when we get to
dairy that's the bridge.
(laughter)
The bridge and the dairy song.
- I'll just get the pack of gum.
- [Nikki] Yeah yeah yeah.
- Put it back, put it back.
- So we have all the vouchers,
do you have like a collecting
vouchers for school?
- [Dan] Yeah.
- So this a big thing in the UK
where were like nectar
cards and all the kind of
so she did like a sort
of freestyle rap about.
- Oh yeah yeah.
- Oh that would be great if
she started busting out bars.
- It was absolutely wonderful.
- Oh man hammered moms.
- I know hammered moms,
I mean we run the game
and my mom has catchphrases.
- Oh really.
- Yeah, she fires us and then
for a while it was bi-atches
she called everyone bi-atches.
She just learned that word,
loved it
and now she's filming people.
- Cool beans.
- She'd get hammered and
she'd be like cool beans.
And you go don't fucking.
- [Nikki] Oh god.
- You know what we should do
is, we should do a competition
where
- A talent show.
- No where you're driving,
kind of like carpool karaoke
you have to drive to a city
and they get your mom hammered.
She gets in the car and you
have to drive her there.
- Oh my god.
- Could you make it, your mom's
hammered.
- That is such a good
show I would watch that.
- Shut the fuck up mom, shut the
fuck up.
- I've done that I mean I
traveled all across America
with my mom.
- Really?
- Oh for a show?
- Yeah for a TV show and
then Thailand and India.
- [Nikki] Wow.
- I was in a traffic jam
with my mom whilst sober
and I'm famous in the UK
so this guy kind of got out
we were in traffic, knocked on
the window
and just went excuse
me can I have a photo,
which is fairly strange.
And my mom went help he's
kidnapping me.
- Oh your mom's hilarious.
- So I said afterwards
why did you do that.
- She said 'cause I'm 60
and I don't give a fuck.
- I love your mom.
- And that was her sober so
drunk, phew.
- Your mom is fun,
rapping 40 minute songs.
- This is it mate, that's why
I took her around the world.
- Oh that makes sense and now
you have
like I also use my
parents a lot in my show
and when I had a show on Comedy
Central
and also like my mom calls into
this show.
- Oh really.
- I just realized like
when she passes away
at some point like I'm gonna
have all this great footage
and people are like why do
you take a blow job class
with your mom and I'm
like 'cause it's funny
and I'm gonna look back on it
and.
- And dad wanted us both there.
(laughter)
- This was dad's idea,
he wrote this scene mom.
- But do you have to, do you
think about that as well.
Like when your mom's
funeral is, god forbid
it's in many many years,
it's gonna be like
we won't have those
traditional kind of like
oh yeah I remember her like,
I'll remember her in a
cacao ceremony in Thailand.
- [Nikki] Yes.
- Do you know what I mean
you have all these weird
kind of strange moments.
- [Nikki] Yes.
- I just remember playing
solitaire in a room in the dark
that's all I got.
- But the reason why, it
was for Comedy Central.
- I'll remember some things
like that too don't worry.
- I remember videoing that,
that was a beautiful moment.
I'll never forget that but
when she's eating a hot dog
with no bun with too much
ketchup in her hands,
I'll always remember that.
- Oh man if my mom weren't
listening,
I would join in on this.
These descriptions.
- So your mom's listening
now, that's pretty cool.
- I assume she might.
- You're fired.
- She sometimes listens
when they're hanging out.
- You start bringing her phrases
out,
what's up bi-atches.
- Nikki you're fired.
- I really like fired
I think that's great.
- You know what Nik, you
know what Nik, screw you
that's what she would say.
Screw you.
- Ashley Heseltine and
Rayna Greenberg were on
the show yesterday show with
Andrew,
there's picture that I posted on
my story
and I cut Andrew out
because the three girl
I just wanted to celebrate
women.
- Yep.
- And then not you.
And so then I posted another
picture
where it was just you.
- And at first I felt
like it was like a dig
but then I was like oh
no it's kind of nice
like you showed me again.
Like when you cut me
off but then put me in.
- Yeah.
- But at first I took it as a
dig.
- No I didn't want it to be a
- I'm gonna white her out and so
then I,
made you a penis.
- Okay.
- I posted it for a second and
then I go
wait that's just mean spirited.
- Yeah you just drew me as
a big and it looks like,
that looks like it
doesn't look like a penis
you didn't even do it the right
color,
it's just a white blob.
Yeah it looks like I'm.
- But I felt like that
was probably a little rude
so I deleted it right away.
- Well I'm glad you
showed it to me right now.
(rock music)
- Oh my god
I know what I wanna do.
Can I get a pen and paper
I just wanna challenge
Andrew to draw something.
You know that guy from Brazil
that I was telling you about
so the other night,
he was talking about how
like oh he's gonna move
to New York because the flight
to Brazil
is so much shorter than it is
from LA.
And I was like oh I guess that
checks out
and he's like yeah like
they're an hour ahead right now
and I was like what do you
mean they're an hour ahead.
- Who's an hour ahead?
- Brazil.
- From where?
- New York.
- Okay.
- And I was like that does not
match up
with where I think Brazil is.
And then I realized my
perception of where
South America is is so
wrong, can I ask you
I just wanna see if I'm as,
'cause I mean this was
embarrassing in front of someone
from South America to see where
I thought South America was
in comparison to North America
was.
I'm gonna draw, you draw.
- From Florida I think I
might have a better sense
because you're from St. Louis.
- Yeah.
Like I don't know Missouri,
Kansas,
I couldn't tell you those
places.
- Well that would be a fun
one to make you draw then.
- So what do you want me to draw
here?
- Erm North America and South
America,
and they can be blobs
I'm not gonna like check
if you know and don't even
put Canada, who cares.
- Yeah, no-one does, this is
like a ...
Like all of it.
- Someone wrote to me being
like I heard you threw some sh.
Oh wait a second I mean
maybe we're not gonna get
out of this.
- It's not to scale.
- That's not, that's not to
nothing,
you don't need to draw like
islands
and the Gulf stream, deltas.
- And then.
- He put in the Bahamas.
- No.
- Okay.
What is that?
- Mexico.
- Okay.
- I think that's right I don't
know.
- Is that Florida right there?
- And then I would say
somewhere,
I know there's Chile is
over here and then Brazil
is around here.
- It doesn't matter I
just wanted the shapes
of South America and North
America.
- Well shit.
- Just start over, okay this
looks like a crude drawing
of a suspect.
First of all, he thinks that's
Florida.
- No no that's California.
- That's Florida and then this
was
supposed to be Mexico.
- That's Mexico.
- So Mexico starts at
and he said before he drew this,
he said I might know
this a little bit better
because I'm from Florida.
He connected Florida and Mexico
you guys.
- You gotta close the border.
- Do you know how wrong that's
- Of Florida
- You wanna build that wall
well actually that wall
the border doesn't even exist
that you wanna build up.
Hold on we have to just see, I'm
sorry
the podcast has gotta wait for a
second
'cause I need to make you draw
this okay,
so draw just the crude
shapes, blobs of South America
and just I wanna see their
location to each other.
- Okay, that's America
and then I would say
that somewhere around here
and then South America
kinda like that and then.
- Okay.
- And then there's like Chile
and here's.
- I don't need, that's
not even close to where
Chile or Brazil are, Chile's
on this side by the way.
- No Chile's on the right.
- Is Chile on the right or left?
- [Man] Left.
- Chile's on this side dude.
- I was cold.
- Okay okay this is way
worse than I thought
it was gonna be and I
am so excited about it
'cause I thought he was gonna.
- Well Mexico's in between
and there's central America.
- I'm gonna blow you pull
up, pull up a world map,
I'm gonna blow your mind right
now.
First of all I thought this as
well,
this was what my drawing looked
like.
- Okay first of all, we live in
America.
- This is what my drawing
looked like the other night,
that's where I was like.
- Okay.
- Right okay, mine's further
away.
- Similar right.
- Okay.
- Okay, look at the map
of where South America is
compared to the United States.
- Should I do a globe?
- No just pull up Google
Maps and then zoom out.
- Oh.
- He's loading transit maps
for San Atonio for some reason
- You never know.
- Keep zooming, keep going.
- Oh god.
- Isn't it worse than you
thought dude.
- Okay wait a second, oh right,
no-one knows it's to the
right, no-one knew that.
- So this is where it is.
- Okay we've both thought.
- I never knew that, I
thought that if you go down
from LA you would hit
South America immediately.
I didn't know by the way,
you don't hit anything.
If you go south from New York
- Yes.
You hit nothing.
- Nothing.
- North America is completely to
the left.
- So why is it not south east
America.
- I don't know I feel like
we need to get this message
out there because clearly
people don't know.
I really thought it was right
under us.
- Is there north, was
America at north and south
called at the same time
or was one found before.
- They named them both at he
same time.
- I don't know, was there a
North America.
- One was named after Amerigo
Vespucci.
- Okay.
- Who was a explorer.
- A designer for Gucci yeah.
We have to start to buy gas.
- In front of his house.
- We can't get into all
this, we know all of this,
we know all, like we have
discussed this for hours about
the
- It is always kind of
annoying when two dumb people
are like, or I'm dumb.
- No I'm really dumb with that
geography.
- And we go and Google exists.
Back in the day you'd be
like whoa you gotta go
to the library or whatever,
you gotta phone a friend.
But now it's like shut
up, stop sounding stupid
and Google it but then again
it's like
I have no idea what America came
first
and maybe we shouldn't
call it South America
because it is south of America.
- But maybe we're north of South
America,
so we should be North South
do you know what I mean
like it should start
with South America, like you
know.
- Well yeah I'm just saying
like,
why are we just calling it South
America,
are we calling it like,
shouldn't it be it's own thing.
- I get what you're saying.
- Like there's Australia,
there's Africa
so it should be North America.
- Why do we even look at the,
why do we look at a world map
from the vantage point that we
all do
where it's like this and
Asia's over here, Africa.
Like why couldn't it be upside
down
because who's to say how
to look at the world,
what's right side up and what's
not.
We're really smart and we
can talk about this all day
but we gotta get to.
- I think it's plate tectonics
actually.
- There is something, that is a
thing.
- There's a, I don't
think the Earth is flat,
I'll give it that.
- Yeah no shit.
- I don't know why.
- You don't know why the Earth
isn't flat.
- I don't know something
about if you fly a plane
you gotta go around.
- Oh that's funny you gotta go
like down,
you gotta make it turn at one
point.
- Yeah you probably.
- Or you just.
- Or you would just keep going.
- Into space.
- Yeah.
- Alright, we learn something.
- Yeah if you're on like
a mountain, mapping.
- That was fun, let's
start the podcast ready.
Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- Alright, hey guys welcome
to You Up the podcast.
(rock music)